[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
la la la la la
foreign
[Music]
laughs
foreign
[Music]
la la la la
foreign
[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to the first
ever games for games showcase you all
this means so much to me and I'm over
it's an understatement to say I'm
Overjoyed that I can finally share this
with you all today dance for games was
created to give women in The Gaming
Community a chance to share their story
contributions and love of games
I wanted this show to highlight some of
the things that women have done in the
industry and continue to do in The
Gaming Community itself and you know as
technical artists as producers as art
directors all the things that we've done
because we love games we've come such a
long way and women have been there since
the beginning you may not have realized
that but we've been there since the
beginning playing games helping to
create the stories and helping to create
the games themselves
now you may have seen me around the
block
you may have seen me hosting on black
voices and gaming another incredible
show that you guys have to catch this
summer which is going to be showcasing
all kinds of black developers who are up
and coming and showing their wonderful
games you may have seen me chatting with
my fam over at the level one 2xp podcast
and you might have caught me in your DMs
trying to help Market Indie Games as the
marketing manager of Freedom Games my
name is Destiny and to say that I'm
thrilled you know I'm already excited to
be here because I helped create this
with a lot of other people like we've
come together to put this show together
but we have so much in store for you
and before we jump into the first
incredible
interview I'm going to let my homegirl
red tell us a little bit about herself
foreign
you said a lot in the nutshell that's
like the commencement speech right there
um hi everyone I'm ready for me you're a
massive eater is also founder of geek
game Thai and a veteran journalist in a
gaming industry like I'm so hyped
because when Destiny first told me about
creating a showcase to shine light on
women and girls from all walks of life
uh in the community I was like sign me
up right away changing the narrative so
uh like Dez also I've been a part of the
mix fam co-hosted black voices in gaming
like she said definitely check out this
summer which is an incredible showcase
um spotlighting a lot of marginalized of
course game developers and give them new
light and shine
and now I have the honor of working with
the dames for games team I'm so excited
about what's about to show in store so
um we have a lot from the community
professionals and also projects led by
some amazing ladies to show today so
y'all stay excited just as long with us
too so all this cannot happen without uh
support needed to even make this come
alive from an idea to what we have
fruition today so definitely let us
everyone know about our support and
partners it's my pleasure so first of
all we would really love to give a shout
out and a huge thank you to Freedom
Games I have to they they just made so
much of this possible they really know
how to make a girl feel special also to
the mixed team who continues to make
waves in the industry and honestly have
been such a great influence and help
they've helped to create spaces like
this and I can't thank them enough
starter is out here kicking butt and
taking names as one of the Premier
places to crowdfund and Market your game
and anything else you really have going
on uh did you guys see what I did with
the joke there yeah yeah comical genius
and also last but not least experience
Studios they're the non-profit
organization that bbig is under that's
black voices and gaming and soon to be
Dames for games so that we can take on
the noble cause to help provide funds to
up-and-coming developers and all the
support they need to create their games
next we'd like to shout out some
partners
Wings an amazing organization working to
help developers reach their dreams geek
game tight
um I believe we have somebody on the
show who like runs geek game type her
name may or may not be red and for me I
don't know
also a taco Noir the creators of the
first blurred box I don't know if you
guys have ever had those like mystery
boxes where you like sign up for them
and get all kinds of goodies but you
need to check out otako Noir they have
some incredible stuff in their boxes and
last but not least I said that twice but
party chat podcast such a dope scene
over at Party Chat podcast if you
haven't checked them out it is a must
they will also be streaming our showcase
huge thank you to Christine she is
incredible
now on to our broadcasting Partners who
without their help you guys would not be
watching right now so that's right let's
not forget them twitch gaming IGN game
jolt Gamespot and steam you all are
incredible because you help us spread
the word about these initiatives and
help us to create the change that we
want to see but um before we jump right
into seeing our first game and our first
developer and talking all things good
red can you tell the people where to
find us if they want to find out more
information
Oh indeed so everyone make sure you
follow us on games for games on Twitter
thanks for games YouTube channel
Instagram and Tick Tock and
last but not least I gotta say just like
you
um all the games are showing throughout
the entire showcase make sure you
definitely check out the steam page
which is the Mexican page where you'll
see a lot of games for game titles by
the about available games that's already
out and make sure you wish list them as
well it really helps the developers kind
of gauge who's interested in that game
so you also get updates as well when it
releases
absolutely if you type in gorilla
Collective 2023 when you go to steam
it'll bring up all of the games from the
gorilla Collective black voices and
gaming and the Incredible games we're
going to show today on Dames for games
but red I just want to say I appreciate
you I love you thank you so much
um as she said you can keep up with our
journey across several social media
platforms but I think it's that time
I think it's time to start the show and
uh give the people what they came for
are we ready
I'm up and ready let's let's get let's
get this going she's been ready she's
been ready all right let's get it going
let's get it going
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
oh my God okay listen I know I get
excited about a lot of things but the
music and like the entire feel of this
game my grandpa used to watch wrestling
like I don't remember when it would come
on but he I swear to God he broke at
least three lazy boys just getting super
excited into it and my grandma would get
so mad and she's watching that wrestling
again but wrestling is hype and I love
that we have a game about it it's so
colorful it's so cool red tell me what
did you think about Russell's story
like just like you mentioned I was I was
bopping to the music and everything but
yeah wrestling
used to watch it when I was little I
even have family that are wrestling my
nephew is a is a up and coming wrestler
so okay
um but the game looks incredible I love
how you could create your own characters
and everything so I can't wait to play
and speak to Zoe awesome well that's who
we have up next Zoe servant the art
director of this incredible game the
Russell story Zoe are you with us
uh hello oh yes I think I'm with you
how's it going thanks for having me good
good no thanks for coming on because I
know as a developer you guys are very
busy you have all these things and the
game's not out yet because you're still
working on it but one of my questions
before we even start to talk about the
game is can you tell us a little bit
about your journey in the industry like
how did you become the art director of
wrestle story
yeah so that's a great question
um so growing up I have always loved
video games I've always loved art
um and I was very fortunate to have two
uh parents who were also artists so they
were always very supportive and
encouraging of me in that Pursuit
um and when I started looking at
colleges and thinking about what I was
going to do for my you know my job or my
life my mom suggested well maybe you
know would you want to work in animation
and I didn't up until that point ever
really consider that that was something
that people did as a job obviously you
know they do someone has to create the
media that we consume but I just never
really thought about it so
um I ended up going to USC for uh at
their interactive game design program
and I was there for four years and then
when I graduated
um I was trying to look for work and I
was really struggling couldn't get
anything I was applying all around
it was very discouraging but I ended up
working in stop motion I ended up
working a lot of freelance and
um all that time I was just applying to
everything I could possibly apply to I
was working on my portfolio on the side
just trying to improve it as much as I
possibly could and eventually I was able
to get a job at an educational games
company and I worked there for a few
months or about eight months until an
old classmate of mine from USC actually
reached out to me and was able to pull
me in a tick tock so that was about four
years ago I've been at Tick Tock for
about four years
and I started as an associate art
director and then eventually moved up to
art director at the studio
so yeah that looks good uh thank you
yeah no the game looks good red red
could not wait y'all she started playing
already so we we're checking out the
game it looks incredible the character
design is great like I'm super excited
but before like I throw it over to Red
um she was bopping to the music really
hard y'all she was bopping to the music
before we even started interviewing like
she was just like what is this like all
all kinds of moves and I know from just
speaking to you earlier that you you
were really excited about the music too
because like it kind of like brought it
to life so as red is getting in here and
and starting her wrestle Journey life
can you tell us about the music
yeah absolutely so the music was made by
a company called a shell in the pit
um they've done a lot of music for
different games
um Rogue Legacy Untitled Goose game
they've got a lot of really talented
artists there so we were fortunate
enough to work with them on uh the Pax
demo that we put together and all of the
music came in really kind of like down
to the wire all the sound effects that
you're hearing in the demo they came in
probably you know
three to two to three weeks before uh
Pax uh packs East so we've been working
on this and then to hear the sound come
in and to hear the music come in I
opened the build one day and I was like
oh my God you're running around Paradise
City and it's like it feels like this
tropical like place it feels so good and
um yeah when my when the game director
Steve sent me the Paradise City
Soundtrack that came in I was like on a
road trip driving up to up north and I
just played it on a loop
um for probably like 10 minutes just
being like oh this is so good I want to
like put it on Spotify like everyone
should get to hear this I can't wait to
put in the game
um yeah that was a really exciting
moment
that's what's up and listen it really
does fit the overall look and and feel
of the game now one of the questions I
wanted to ask as an art director because
a lot of people may not know what it is
you do like specifically at the at the
um company my words are like leaving my
brain it's because I'm hungry it's
because I'm hungry but so can you tell
us a little more about like being an art
director and kind of the role that you
play when it comes to creating games
yeah absolutely so my role you know for
the past two and a half years we've been
working on this game it's been a very
small team myself
um our game director our lead programmer
just sort of incubating the idea and for
the past two years pretty much my role
as the art director has been figuring
out you know obviously how it's going to
look setting style parameters around the
UI the visual effects the character
designs the environment figuring out how
they all kind of mesh together and then
figuring out how
we you know can scale that up in a 3D
sense so figuring out how
um
you know some some characters look good
in a 2d sketch and then when you
transform that into a 3D World you have
some weird stuff going on
so there was a lot of iteration on that
a lot of exploration
um so yeah for the first two years my
job was mostly concepting and style
establishing so doing a lot of Art and
my job now has transformed a little bit
I think you know when people hear art
director they do think you're doing a
lot of art but the truth is once your
team becomes large enough the job really
does become more management
um and sort of production Focus so
doing a lot of red lines giving feedback
writing up assignments
um and there's a little bit of a balance
in there because I like to get in and
get my hands dirty too so yeah
yeah
I love that red how are you doing I I
didn't I didn't pay attention to which
characters but I can tell you're the one
with the pink pompadour that's you right
that's not you yeah
wait a minute
that one's tricky so yeah we're all of
the different moves are gonna have
different Action commands associated
with them so
you know the body slam has a hold the
joystick up and release other moves will
have you know different timing button
presses you'll see a little bit more if
you get that far in the demo but
um yeah we wanted to give the player a
lot to do during combat I think people
will sometimes hear turn-based
combat and it kind of worried that it
won't be super engaging but wrestling is
all about the drama it's all about you
know the hard hits so we wanted to make
sure that that is coming through for the
player even in a turn-based game keep
them engaged I love the character design
I I love the character design so much
like it's just so fun you know and then
like the the entire city I just want to
run around it and explore it like
everything just looks so well put
together it's very cohesive
red tell us your thoughts like you're
actually in there playing the game like
how do you feel about it
uh I mean so far like even starting out
I love the banter already and even the
different dialogue that you can choose I
love when you can actually pick what you
want to say so if you want to be a
little quirky Sinister or it was very
professional or whatever and a way you
want to be with your dialogue then you
can but
I love how I look I love that you can
create your own uh character in some
type of way I love the skin tones y'all
know I love you got to be melanated and
sometimes I gotta have some variety yeah
yeah so I love that people are able to
choose what they want and it is a
different spin on wrestling games uh so
I feel like anyone and everyone can
actually play it so it's it's dope I do
have a question Zoe
uh so what animation like I have some
friends that develop or you know or make
uh animation as far as with film what
would you say is some of the the
obstacles you had to overcome with being
an animator
that is a great question I think the
biggest obstacle and this is something
that we're still kind of working through
figuring out you know ironing out the
Kingston is
um you know you mentioned the character
design something being something that
you really liked that that has posed an
interesting
um some interesting challenges to us you
know originally we had a lot of
characters that were sort of a little
bit more uniform in their shape which
makes it a little bit easier to have
characters of different you know of
similar shapes picking them picking each
other up and throwing them
um but we decided that we wanted to
really push that push and pull the
proportions you'll see characters that
are really large you know they got these
giant shoulders so they got big heads
they got big feet and they're picking up
and throwing characters that are really
small
um you know maybe
two to three times smaller than them
um and figuring out how to get
animations on one character to you know
a body slam on one character to look
good on a body slam on you know the same
animation character
um that has been a challenge
um but I think that you know
where we've landed with it is successful
but there's always something funky that
goes on when you put a new animation in
there and you're like all right let's
try this on the big boss character and
see how it looks
um you never quite know you're kind of
crossing your fingers and hoping that
nothing crazy is gonna happen
um
but I think that's probably been the
main the main obstacle for us is is
because we've pushed our characters so
far design wise it does
um you know it raises a couple a couple
questions of how's the animation when
they're throwing each other around the
ring so that's really important it's a
wrestling game you know right and it's
looking like spectacular and first of
all like our our interview times are
always so short like I always want to
ask a ton more questions and get like
really really in depth with it because
there's so many things that go into
creating a game and we've only scratched
the surface okay guys we've only
scratched the surface but hopefully we
can bring you back we can bring
Russell's story back and then we can get
more in depth about like other things
that you guys are doing with the game
now I don't know if I can ask this but
I'm asking anyways is there like a time
frame of a demo that's gonna drop so our
viewers and others can check it out for
themselves and experience the Russell
story
um So currently we don't have a release
date The plan is you know we are going
to release it when it's good and ready
and we're happy with it and we think
that people will really enjoy it
um we are looking for a publisher so
hopefully by the time this interview
comes out we've got you know some fun
updates on that but you know obviously
external funding will really have to
move that release date closer
um but right now what we're planning is
Pax West is probably the next time
people will be able to play the game
we're hoping to have you know you saw in
the demo there was sort of character
presets that you could choose from we're
working right now on an even more
fleshed out character creator that's got
a lot of variety in it so hopefully I
love the next time you can play the game
we can showcase that yeah because that
was kind of the biggest feedback that we
got from people at patch was that they
just wanted to make their own wrestler
which is like yeah totally fair that's
exactly what I wanted to
um so yeah I'm really excited to be able
to show that off and
Pax West will be when when we're able to
show more of the content that we've been
creating thank you Zoe So if you guys
are going to be at Pax West make sure to
stop by their Booth they were at PAX
East it was incredible I know we're
running on time but they actually had a
wrestler stop by and people were losing
their mind Zoe and like 30 seconds maybe
less can you tell us a little bit about
that the wrestler who stopped yeah how
to play your game
yeah so uh Austin Creed who is uh he
goes by Xavier Woods he's a WWE wrestler
um he was doing a panel for his um his
up up down down show and somebody
mentioned our game he came down and he
checked out the flyer took a picture of
it and then we heard about that and we
were like wow that's amazing we hope
that he comes by and he actually did end
up coming by the next day and playing
the game he hung out with us for a
little bit it was really cool to meet
him very surreal moment to see him
that's awesome
he's in the game
you never know someone will tell we got
a lot of debt ahead of us so that's true
that's true well Zoe thank you so much
for spending some time
and coming on and talking with us
letting us play your game and show our
audience if people want to keep up with
you and want Tick Tock games is doing
and if they want to just keep up on
Wrestle story can you drop your socials
for us
yeah absolutely so my socials uh just my
name's always servant but um if you want
to keep up to date on what the game is
on what's happening with the game you
can check out Tick Tock games on Twitter
um t-i-c-t-o-c games not uh the video
app and you can also check out Russell's
story on Steam give us a wish list
that's super helpful for us in our in
our uh publisher hunt
um and you'll also get updates as we you
know announce closer to release and
everything like that
awesome Zoe once again
no thank you because I I know developers
are busy and this has been so incredible
all of our guests have been super super
awesome and you are no exception so
I appreciate it so much but thank you
thank you guys so much
you're welcome we have Zoe was just
wrestle story was just the first
interview okay we have so much more to
show you
and I just I feel like you're gonna be
blown away I read I I'm running out of
words red red to talk to the people
I'm gonna follow up let me give you the
follow-up all right but everyone y'all
in store like for some epicness dopeness
epicness all from people that are alike
that love the passion for gaming ladies
out there from whatever age whatever
Walk of Life we do exist okay we do
exist we create we innovate here in this
space and we're about to show you more
of that during a danger game showcase so
stay tuned stay tuned guys and any of
the games that you see in today's
showcase including Russell's story make
sure to check out gorilla Collective
2023 on Steam no wishlist some of those
games they are incredible the ones we're
gonna show later are incredible and also
there are going to be some cool games
with black voices and gaming and just
the gorilla collective in general so
what you it's the summer time this is a
perfect time to go wishlist games and go
buy some games so go do it
and uh we'll catch you in the next
interview
yo Russell's story looked amazing and
everyone remember whatever you see
throughout the show wish listed on Steam
our steam page it helps support the
developers and let them know
specifically who's interested in the
game so make sure you support that way
if you want the game or just to support
in general so up next we have a special
guest from The Gaming Community all
right but before we jump into our guests
we have a new player coming in a new
host and I'm Gonna Leave to you hugger
what is up red I am excited to be here
my name is the floor hugger you guys
might see me at level one more than
anything else you know doing podcasts
being weird on Tuesdays and just
enjoying things you can find me all
across social media you'll find me on
Tick Tock the most it's all the floor
Huggers so if you just want to hang out
for a bit go play some valorant with me
I'll be down for that
yeah you gotta you gotta um get me into
the Apex and everything and valorate
because
I've been slacking a bit got you but we
do have a fellow shooter here okay we
have cells from the community who is a
huge Halo fan so sales welcome in
hello hi
thank you for having me
it's an honor thank you for being here
listen I've seen your content I've seen
you in these Halo streets so let us know
like your humble beginnings in gaming
so
pretty much I
grew up with a bunch of boys like we all
lived on the same block and we all hung
out in each other's basements and played
video games and um
I've always been exposed to video games
even if like I wasn't playing it like if
it was either my uncles or my cousins or
my brother like there was always a
console in the house and even if I
wasn't playing with it at the time I
just I was always exposed to video games
whether I was gonna play or not but
luckily for me I got into it and um
I
you know I ended up making friends
um growing up who
were the big reason why I got into Halo
and we ended up just always hanging out
in each other's basements eating pizza
and like you know hanging out till three
in the morning
doing like system links and stuff
well that's that's taking it way back
right hooker that's that's taking it
away
we're doing a LAN party everybody bring
your console over well we all had our
book bags with our Xboxes in it and
stuff
[Music]
you made me almost shed a tear for a
second there
so so being a mom a lot of a lot of
people don't understand a lot of times
like I'm an auntie okay but being a mom
and a gamer like
how how is that and do you find yourself
even teaching your children about video
games as well
[Music]
well I always say that thanks to my
oldest son I got back into gaming
um
I've only like I've only played on
consoles my son is the PC kid like he
has you know like he's really into his
gaming and everything and
um I've always found myself going back
and forth like I'll have a moment where
I'll binge and play video games for a
specific amount of time then you know
Mom life happens and then I
really find myself not having as much
time
um
one day my son comes up to me he's like
you know there's a new Halo game coming
out and I was like oh really he's you
should play and from there on I got back
into it and it was like I was just so
happy that I was able to I missed it you
know it was something that I look
forward to whenever I needed like a
moment and you know needed a break and
um it was cool because I just feel like
now I have something more to connect
with my son so we'll you know and as
I've been you know
um
becoming more familiar with the world of
gaming and like speaking to more people
within the Gaming Community Learning
about other titles and stuff like that
it's what influenced me to start
streaming and I will thank my son for it
he was like Mom you should just get back
on and play again because he's so he
he's always seen me dabble at video
games here and there since he was a baby
and you know I guess
it's from seeing me
play here and there Pat him into it yeah
so we inspired each other I guess
or do you have anything to ask said she
was shooter you know you got a fellow
shooter right here okay Halo I got no
aim though that's the thing
I love shooters but I can't aim what's
your favorite Halo because I'm now
getting into Halo
Halo
Halo so
I I could say Halo 3 because you know
that's like the go-to for everyone in
the 360 generation because that was like
the first like that was my first real
console that I had went to GameStop and
bought waited online for Halo 3 got the
legendary edition the helmet with all
the with all the games inside like
in the background
yeah
um I do have a soft spot
for Halo 2 because that's where that's
what me and my friends played
and then
story-wise Halo 4 has my heart I sobbed
immensely when I played that campaign
hey that's fair they are all fantastic
games a very in quality for some people
but it's a franchise that has been what
20 years now like yeah there's a reason
why
do you play any other games but Halo
yeah
um fortnite has me in a chokehold
right now that's that's my go-to multi
right now yes like if I don't know what
to play if I'm just like oh I don't know
what I'm in the mood for I'm just like
well let me just play fortnite like and
then um I play OverWatch I just recently
got into OverWatch
um I also played Call of Duty
um and trying to like you know try other
things like I always try and
Counter-Strike
um Battlefield and stuff like that I
I want to like learn more
um Shooters and get familiarized and
you know incorporate that when I stream
like because that's what my main focus
is when it comes to streaming just like
shooting things so the more games I can
like expose myself to I'm down for it
those are my foreign
so as a as a content creator right as a
content creator and also as a as a mommy
I love to say mommy gamer how do you
balance it all because from streaming to
playing the latest games and even
dabbling in different games all at once
how do you balance that even
um you know being a mommy gamer at the
same time
to be completely honest like I'm still
figuring it out myself
like um schedule wise and everything at
first when I started I was just going
with the flow like
if I had you know like in reality it's
like on the weekends when the kids go
with their dad and stuff and stuff so
like that would be when I would
but um I since there's been more of like
a growth within my channel and stuff
like that like wow I really need to like
start setting up you know be a little
bit more consistent because
um like I care about the viewers and
stuff and you know they like
how I play and how I interact and you
know like
at the end of the day for me it's just I
always considered when I hop on streams
like it's just me hanging out with my
friends you know I um like I go on I'm
like hi guy like you know it'll like I
always felt like this like the people
who join in and like hang out with me on
my stream
it's like these would be like people I
would hang out with and play video games
with
you know if we were all in my house
hanging out
so
yeah like so at first you know I would
just wing it and
wait till the kids go to bed or while
the kids are in school and everything
like that so little by little I'm trying
to like
figure out a decent schedules to be more
consistent so it's been it's it's a
little hard because
um
you know like times like this for
example like
anything to happen
kids are I try to like get them to nap
and I'm like yeah
I'm here like streaming and my daughter
just like jumps on me and she's like Mom
I want a snack like okay
so I'm still this is still work in
progress
so
um so have you introduced like any games
uh like to your twins because you
mentioned you have twins as well and
they're they're younger than uh yeah
eldest so have you introduced a play any
games with them I got them involved too
Angry Birds
I feel like that's the go-to
-date but yeah see I say it she's like
Angry Birds like yeah that was
I know like my my son that was his first
game
and he was like all about it had all the
plushies had books like I think I have
one of his old books here from when they
want to join they're more than welcome
if they want to join oh one of them I
have one of those
these are like myself
yeah like he was all about like Angry
Birds and Plants vs Zombies like these
were his games so I was like hey you
know like these are the games that my
oldest son started playing when he was
their age so now I introduced it to them
and I'm like oh I guess you know these
are the building blocks to making gamers
I love that okay
core memories right there that's
adorable and you are adorable your kids
are adorable and
just stay sitting with you right now
makes me so happy
thank you thank you
yeah I love your content so
before we we head out is it as far as
anything you want to share and also
where can we find you and catch a
content
um so
what I would like to share is
um within the Gaming Community I
primarily want to focus on Gamers
um or neurodiverse like my youngest son
he's on the Spectrum he has autism and
you know sharing his story as his
caregiver I was able to connect with a
lot of you know Gamers who are on my to
come to my stream who you know
are on the Spectrum have autism ADHD and
you know
a lot of the times they you know have
difficulty you know navigating within
the Gaming Community like
getting to know others and
I always
honor them like I always like I would
love to you know
create a space where I can
you know
show off you know different neurodiverse
Gamers who are who aren't afraid to
share their stories on mental health and
stuff like that so that's one thing and
also just connecting Gamers that are
moms and
you know
um the same way like how do you know
like
talk and vent about mommyhood and about
games and stuff it's just like I just
want to build a community of you know
people that I can relate to you know
because I as a neurodiverse mother of
three it's like
the best way to
you know
connect with others is to find people
who are similar to you and
build like a family
that's amazing yeah listen you you have
a family here as well to help you do
that yeah
so just let us know and um as far as
your Twitch and and your your Twitter as
well is it all um I am sales
yeah everything's the same my um
Instagram
my twitch my Twitter my YouTube channel
everything's hi I'm so it's nice and
easy
yeah I heard it every once yeah
definitely check out
Tick Tock too I need to work yeah
but thank you so much for for joining
hugger and I and being a part of things
for games uh so thank you so much and
share your story and letting us know how
you start your humble beginnings and
also your family that you got involved
with gaming as well thanks so much
thank you again I really really
appreciate this opportunity you guys are
amazing
honest thank you
so hugger what would you what you think
so far like
yeah sales on she does it
listen
salute to cells okay we just go upstairs
oh because that's a lot I think a lot of
people don't understand balancing family
and and also doing your passion as well
so shout out to all the mommies the
aunties the grandmas the TTS the tias
and everyone out there
that try to balance join games right now
exactly exactly it's not easy
because she's just trying to have fun
too and I can I mean we can speak from
us sometimes gaming it's hard it's hard
to have fun find fun and the fact that
she's done it and is bringing her family
in that's admirable admirable that is so
adorable too and
[Music]
kind of you know hide everything nobody
can tell when I'm crying there's a
reason for the glasses
nobody can tell what I'm about to cry
because I need that so we have some more
some more uh we have some more
incredible people heading up next so hug
and share what we got
[Music]
you know before we get into that you
might want to take a look at the steam
page there's going to be some great
games out there that you might get a
nice discount on that you want to play
but if you're excited now if you're
excited for what just happened you'll be
super excited with our next segment
which is the star player and Michelle is
going to take it home for us stay tuned
for more from games for games I'm the
floor hugger you know where to find me I
hope you all have a great day and all my
socials are all the same thanks floor
hugger that was a great interview it's
amazing to see how many people manage to
game and create content all while being
a parent
women have been in the gaming industry
since the industry's beginnings
legendary women like Roberta Williams
Carol Shaw Mabel Addis Muriel tremi and
Donna Bailey have paved the way for our
star players our star players are the
women who are making waves in gaming in
The Gaming Community today here are
their stories
oh
you are now rocking with the hostess
with mimosas this is your girl the
natural hair gamer Janae Renee and I'm a
games journalist in the industry
anything that has to do with diversity
inclusion bringing in more women
bringing in more black people you can
always find a trace of me I actually
wrote a book an e-book that helps games
journalists or aspiring games
journalists be better at their craft or
get into the profession so I shared all
of my tools with you guys anything you
want to know is in that book I'm
currently working on a documentary about
women in the gaming industry worldwide
so I just got back from Europe talking
to all these amazing women who work in
the games industry not just as
programmers but artists release managers
job set we probably never even heard of
the point of the documentary is to
educate Inspire and inform to let women
of all walks of life know that they can
be a part of the gaming industry so I
can't wait to share the full documentary
with you guys so until next time game
safely
nice to meet you I'm a visual narrator
with a background in illustration and
game design on the side I like to make
videos from my streams where I play
indie games for all my loved ones and
friends to watch
um in general my interest in games kind
of comes from the love of the fact that
there's so many levels of collaboration
in this art form from when you make it
from when you want others to play it and
then when you want to play it with
others to share
um I think
though when I will play games I really
enjoy the fact that I'm able to explore
another world and really pushing those
limits of what the game already allows
me to explore and really just like
enjoying the narrative that another
person's trying to tell me it's for me a
very beautiful form of Storytelling and
I think that I'd love to hear more of
other people's worlds and perspectives
it was so nice to meet you I really like
Mario Kart it's like the best game ever
hello my name is buff Garden I'm a
full-time variety streamer on Twitch and
I've been streaming for nine years well
just about nine years uh gaming has
always been a hobby since I was born
just absolutely been passionate about it
forever as long as I can remember it's
brought me and family and so many
friends together and I absolutely love
it it's provided me with a job that I've
done on Twitch again for nine years
which I'm so so grateful for and just
brought me so many amazing memories and
has really brought me and a bunch of new
people and new friends together and I'm
just so grateful for what games have
done for me with twitch I was able to
move to Australia and pursue my dream of
living here which is so amazing and
clearly it's just like many people
provided me hours and hours and hours of
entertainment and joy my name is Zelda
Oakley and my mom's looking designer
for Freedom Games
and I love games because I get to play
with them with Mommy and Daddy my name
is Aziza Brown
I am the CEO and founder of dynamic
Focus we are an Esports team that has
been in operation since 2016.
we focus on fighting games we have been
traveling and also we have been working
with different content creators to grow
their brands and make them more
acceptable for the marketplace so they
can grow and be a entity of their own
also I am the investor in the queen of
the Hill series a series for women
non-binary and feminine identified and
competitors casters and production
people to be noticed by the industry I'm
for Teo talks a podcast that talks about
the industry at large about tournament
organizing our social Dynamic focus on
every single one Twitter Facebook
everything remember Dynamic Focus for
the k
it I like to play
to kabuka I like to play Subway Surfers
I like to play
my Nintendo switch what do you play on
your Nintendo switch Super Smash Bros
Minecraft oh and I picked coffee and
and Minecraft
do you guys love video games yeah
yeah do you guys want to play a lot of
them yes
I know I was talking
to what is I'm talking about what we
record a subscription box service we
created this during the height of the
pandemic because we missed visiting
black creators and creatives of color at
the local conventions
so we decided to create a service where
these concert creators can have their
work shared with our audiences
speaking of our audience we are so lucky
and so happy to be teaming up with games
for games and black voices and gamings
to give our subscribers a lot of awesome
merch that you honestly don't want to
miss out on this is to promote our
September gaming box
one more kicker
one lucky subscriber will win a really
great prize so stay tuned for more
details
hey my name is Casino I am originally
from Minsk but currently living in
bathroom and I'm the creator of flawless
selfie
I have a really diverse range of
interests including drawing crafting
with different materials cooking playing
various instruments and game
art has always been a significant part
of my life I have acute skills in
drawing graphic design composition
animation game design and I continue to
learn new things every day
the question of why I love games is
really important to me as it relates to
how I perceive art as a player you are
not only an observer rather you become
an actor on a stage alongside other
participants who can help you or
manipulate you and even be real humans
Just Like You When developing Indie
Games it is more likely that you have to
be a generalist to some extent although
my strongest youth I think lies in our
Direction being a team leader is a
really hard work
but love what you do do what you love
and everything will fall into places
there are many reasons as to why I love
gaming but one of the most important
reasons is the ability that games have
to transport us into a different
experience it makes us laugh makes us
cry it gives us different perspectives
um provides an opportunity for us to
connect and that's what I love about my
community or The Gaming Community is the
ability that we can have to connect with
each other to laugh together to cry
together to rage together and sometimes
it brings up topics and conversations
that I think need to be had and games
provides that I love meeting with my
community each week and just
connecting and games provides that
hey my name is Jessica I am the pr
director at Uber strategist a PR and
marketing agency serving the video game
tabletop and Technology Industries I've
been gaming basically since I got my
first Super Nintendo console I don't
even remember what age now but
um yeah Gaming's been one of my biggest
passions in life ever since I met with
developers
um as media
and I was just really inspired by their
passion for their projects and their
hard work and just all the Blood Sweat
and Tears that goes into their work and
I decided that I wanted to be on the
other side of that helping them make
their projects a success and ultimately
I landed at Uber strategist who um I
have to give big props to just for
enabling me to become the best version
of myself and make a living doing what I
love to do in a leadership role that I
never thought was actually possible for
myself women just have such an important
role to play in this industry and bring
value to any team fortunate enough to
have them and my message to other women
and girls that aspire to find a career
here you can do it you can absolutely do
it and don't settle for anything else
less than you deserve so thank you for
the amazing team at Dames and Games for
having me this was a lot of of fun and
I'm so excited to see more women join
this industry and make it bigger and
better than ever
hi my name is Quinn and I'm eight years
old and my favorite video game so far
for right now is uh uh Legend of Zelda
tears of the kingdom and I like that
video game mostly because you get to
collect stuff and make weapons I like
getting to see other people
um likes other people's perspective like
the character's perspective in the game
I think girls in games are important
because girls perspectives are kind of
important when they mix with games
I hope everyone has a good showcase and
things stands for games
[Music]
la
that was really great glad to see so
many women from every age and background
enjoying gaming you can keep up with all
their progress at games for games on
Twitter and across social media I'm
Michelle Franklin narrative designer of
recombobulator games you can find me on
Twitter Instagram and Tick Tock at
author Michelle Franklin and now on to
Jenny
thanks so much Michelle and what an
incredible highlight of women in the
industry now it's time to change gears
and take a look at some upcoming games
created by women-led teams
[Music]
laughs
foreign
[Music]
thank you
from a developer that brought you Mass
Effect 3 and Dead Space 2 comes at noon
narrative Adventure
explore worlds filled with carpet-based
life forms
[Music]
crew of The Intergalactic cruise ship
princess Andromeda
and help the Galaxy's
Space Cat detective stuff a
shape-shifting jewel thief before it's
too late
sail with inspector Domino for an
adventure of interplanetary proportions
in space mode
[Music]
it went
[Applause]
[Music]
we'll be free
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
do you remember the world of childhood
how it failed to have knee bruises on
pine needles stuck in your fingers
the wind in your hair and putting
carelessness
[Applause]
[Music]
but also
overcoming the difficult times and
Injustice building friendships that last
a lifetime can be tricky but don't be
afraid my little pie mama will always be
there when you feel alone
experience the magic of childhood again
with Sanya
[Music]
thank you
whew a quick breather before we dive
into some more games remember one of the
best ways to stay updated on titles that
you're excited about is to wish list
them on Steam it's good for the
developers and can help make sure that
you don't lose track of the final game
when it's out and ready to play because
you'll get a little notification when it
launches ready to fill up your wish
lists well stay tuned because part two
of our montage is ready to go and we've
got lots more to share
wind spell the Crafters Paradise you
still can't believe that you finally
managed to open your own storefront here
[Music]
groundskeeper Bill and please please or
better or just Bellon
I understand that you offer smithing
service is here
[Music]
you're not sure what exactly you're
going to sell yet
that you reason depends on what the
customers ask for you're flexible less
flexible is the feeding schedule of your
pet owl cat meow
let's have a look
[Music]
are you the only the owner
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
Waters become the new gold only a
handful of managed to survive
in a world where even water is scarce
unlimited growth isn't an option because
every little bit counts
in this unforgiving place nothing lasts
forever
adapt to a nomadic lifestyle
[Music]
Applause and Technologies to kick-start
progress when you
snow into the dangers of the Wasteland
but with your guidance your survivors
just might make it through the night
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
sexiest monsters will compete for your
affection what's the worst that could
happen
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
it's always exciting to see what's in
store for us and these titles were no
exception a huge thank you to all of the
teams joining in for the festivities of
Dames for games and if you'd like to
stay on top of what's happening in the
Indie world and discover more indie
games please feel free to follow me at
kimchika on Tick Tock twitch and YouTube
and a major thank you to the dames for
games team for including me in the fun
and festivities now let's check back
with red and Destiny to see what else
they've got in store for the rest of the
show
thank you
big shout out to all of our star players
who let us share their stories we truly
appreciate it Michelle and Jenny were
absolutely fabulous if any of you out
there want to share your story with us
we're here for it hit us up on our
socials because we want to know why you
love games as much as we do and uh you
just might be featured in our next
showcase but before we get to our next
guest I can't believe we're already
halfway through we already have it can
you believe we're already halfway
through like
red I want more like
we have more right because we we have
more we we have a lot more but before we
jump into like our next guest tell me uh
what did you think about the trailer
Montage I was 16 games signed 16 games
that we showed off what'd you think a
hot 16. hot 16. I thought it was
incredible I love seeing it was a a
great diverse bunch of games too
absolutely like something for everyone
and that's what I love about our
showcase is that not only of course is
representation of of all women uh from
all ages all walks of life but then we
get to see the diversity of these
women-led projects as well because a lot
of people out there still it's 20 23 and
they still think that women are not
passionate about games that were not
creators of video games content creators
competitors you name it they just think
we just play Candy Crush and that's it
so we have something like this to show
that that doesn't just exist so I'm
excited I can't wait to dive into our
next guest Destiny I know you're gonna
do the honors of introducing what I call
our new players and guest hosts
absolutely so we have a special guest
host who's going to be doing the next
interview with me you guys stay tuned
because you might learn a lot about what
it takes to be a developer
[Applause]
[Music]
okay
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
the show has been so incredible so far
we've had trailers we've had our special
star segment where you guys got to see
women in the community and in the
industry talking about the changes that
they're making and creating the change
that they want to see in the community
and in the industry but we still have a
whole bunch more to go I hope you
enjoyed the video that we just showed
you from the wings Foundation they're
they're incredible they are you know
what I'm not gonna I'm not gonna jump
into it I'm not gonna tell you what
they're going to do first I'm going to
get us over to our new guest host I'm
gonna let her introduce herself and then
she's going to introduce our guests to
talk more about what Wings does because
she's the expert and you know it's her
world we're just living in it so go
ahead Nico
hi I'm so happy to be here my name is
Miko Charbonneau and I've been in the
game industry about nine years mostly as
a game designer in AR and VR and on
games like Minecraft and some smaller
titles and right now I run the studio
pretty smart games which you can find
out more about if you go to
prettysmartgames.com
but enough about me let's meet Karina
Diaz from wings
Karina are you there hi
hello hello hi great to join you no
thank you thank you for I know you guys
are very very busy so thank you for
coming on and like we just we want to
jump right into it Wings has done so
many amazing things for women in
developing and marginalized voices can
you tell us a little bit about yourself
how you got started with them and kind
of like what you guys have planned for
the future because I know you're doing
big things
I would love to
um so thanks for having me my name is
Karina Diaz I work with wings on many
many different projects but everything
that has to do with communication so
that's kind of my specialty and why I'm
happy to be here with you today
um I'm certainly uh Keen to talk about
what Wings does and you know how we've
how we've grown over the last few years
um I think for myself I joined Wings in
2020 when it was just a concept that was
born out of the GDC Relief Fund uh you
may have heard of it due to covid it was
started and as a result we found you
know there were a lot of developers in
need and specifically women developers
who are in need of funding and support
all kinds of resources so that's really
where Wings came from I joined as I said
sort of early on and since then we've
gone on to do really amazing things work
with lots of great teams and yeah plan
some really special events that I think
we'll talk more about today
yeah definitely one of the things that I
wanted to ask you about and then I'm
gonna throw it over to Miko because she
has some incredible questions from
coming from a developer side but I know
and this will be a great segue I know
that you've been working with Netflix to
kind of start this program that also
helps up and coming developers can you
tell us a little bit about that
absolutely so uh this is the Elevate
program that I think you're referencing
it's the second time we've done an
Elevate program which is intended to be
a bit of an incubator uh for gender
marginalized devs to refine their pitch
get their project sort of ready to show
off so sometimes create a prototype or
polish a prototype and the current
version of elevate is sponsored by
Netflix so we've put a focus on mobile
games I think most people know you know
this is sort of a hot and up and coming
area of the industry it's something that
increases accessibility for a lot of
people so we're really keen on mobile
games even though it's something a
little bit new in terms of a focus for
the Elevate program the program is going
to take 10 teams it gives them a
financial stipend of ten thousand
dollars it gives them mentorship support
Connections in the industry really
everything that they would need I think
to again sort of get a project ready to
take to that next stage of funding or or
you know publisher support and that's
very much in line with what we do at
Wings we we try to give that sort of
holistic support to our teams not just
money but also the connections and the
mentorship that you know really make
make a big difference in this industry
Dave that's incredible like that that is
really what we should be doing and and
you're right like I know so many people
like they don't consider themselves
Gamers but if you play games you're a
gamer right like we don't even need
titles but so much 100 right so many
people yep so I'm gonna play games on
phones and it some of the games that
come out on phones now and on mobile are
incredible like so well done and I I
love that like you you guys are really
encompassing them because I feel like a
lot of people who or a lot of developers
who are making games on phones and in
Mobile like they kind of get I don't
know they kind of get a little shade
right so they do they do yeah
no and there's a lot of great games that
will end up on phones in the future um
games that you're probably used to
seeing on a console or a PC that are now
being
um ported into a more accessible and
portable format um and there's there's
absolutely nothing wrong with that I
think anytime as a developer you can
have more people experience your game um
and whether that be more people you know
in terms of your sales numbers or just
more people all over the world like a
diverse group of of fans that you can
build for your studio
um yeah that's where the mobile
Advantage lies and you know having said
that obviously we're still looking at
funding PC and console games at wings
that's a huge Focus but the Elevate
program does
um yeah sort of open up the door I think
for some of the developers who are
looking to explore the mobile market and
obviously with a sponsor like Netflix uh
they're going hard and heavy into games
and we're really really excited just you
know to have their support for women
love it and shout out to Netflix y'all
are doing the work thank you so much
like that's what's up because when I
first heard about it I was like yo
Netflix isn't on this like that's dope
yeah but I should mention too we've
partnered with code coven on it who's a
you know a great um organization in the
UK If you haven't heard of code coven
please go check them out
um so Wings you know just we really seek
out Partners in the industry you share
our values and
um you know can make real opportunities
happen
um for marginalized developers that's
that's our mission
you know diversity is the key like
everybody plays games it's not just a
one person or one group like we're all
playing games which is one of the
reasons why we put this showcase
together but I'm gonna stop talking I'm
gonna throw it over to Mikko because she
has some very specific and wonderful
questions if you guys are developers
watching this like please please tune in
because Miko like the list is it's long
but questions all the questions are
important and I just know that that
wasn't to throw shade I wish we could
ask all the questions so I had her like
put the most important I like to over
prepare this okay listen I am right
there Bring it on I am right there with
you but as a small Indie Dev I wear many
hats and one of them is executive
producer so I have to be preparer for
things I do
um but yeah Karina that's awesome I
actually play uh some of the Netflix
games and I've been really impressed
with their platform so I'm really really
excited about this program
um but yeah I did put together some
questions that I think small uh you know
maybe developers that are hobbyists or
Solo devs or just starting out might be
curious about and to start off I was
wondering when you get a pitch deck at
Wings what are some things that that we
can do to make our pitch deck stand out
like are there some things that you wish
we did more or that maybe people who are
new to pitching don't always think of
that's a great question
um and and it comes up a lot truthfully
there's not uh anything I'm going to
tell you in this answer that's going to
guarantee that your pitch will will sort
of stand out and shine I think I think
the project is is really the basis for
that um but beyond you know the the core
concept that you're pitching
um being organized having some of the
fundamentals in your pitch deck um and
in fact if you visit the Wing's website
on our blog we have an article about how
to create pitches there's lots of great
resources available
um but I think you know there are some
Basics that we expect to see and
certainly having a plan for
um the money that you're asking for I
mean that sounds like such an obvious
thing to include but sometimes
developers you know think that they have
an idea of what they need to get their
game to the finish line but they may not
be taking into account things like play
testing or marketing or PR or
localization there's there's just so
many items that can go into a budget and
I think that you know a solid pitch
would include your intention for making
the best use of the money that you're
asking for it's a lot easier I mean we
fund projects up to 500k so we need to
have some idea of
um you know where those funds are being
allocated and in a sense the developers
who apply get to make those decisions so
showing us that you've thought about
that decision process and you know sort
of have a have a plan in place for if we
say yes is very important and other than
that like I said the quality of your
pitch often depends on the project and
the ability to to present it clearly
all right yeah
see a short time but we gotta no it's
okay yeah and I feel bad because like
honestly I would love like I'm just
gonna say now I would love to have you
back on at some point Karina because I
really do feel like some of these
questions are important and we do have
developers who are going to be watching
this and so like Mikko Karina we're
gonna do something long form where we
can really get all these questions
answered because we only have a short
time but yeah and even that question was
so valuable because it was about budget
a lot of Indies don't think about that
they're just thinking about the creative
side right like your localization yeah
yeah of course
yeah but we're we're about to like wrap
it up but before we do before we wrap it
up Karina I feel like you might have
some news to share with us like like
some news you want to drop on us like
I'm excited about it I do and then so
after you drop that exciting news I'm
sorry I didn't mean to cut you off but
after you drop it because this is very
important we want everybody to know
where they can find you your socials
where they can find out more about wings
which I feel like is very simple you
need to look up wings but it's not
simple she's going to put all that
information out for you so go ahead
absolutely
um I mean yeah so really quick news
we've got some great games that we've
signed recently that are coming um a
couple names to check out Atlas wept Psy
of the Abyss um and The Whispers of the
West is one that's coming up very soon
it will be launching July 13th if you've
just learned it's a sort of murder
mystery game for one to four People
Co-Op uh really really fun and unique
especially if you want to get together
with friends but you can play it by
yourself as well so July 13th that will
drop otherwise if you want to learn more
about wings uh wingsfund.me is our
website uh you'll find us at wingsfundme
almost on all socials and if you do have
some questions about pitching what we
look for in terms of Beyond gender
diversity in a team and how we how we
fund and provide mentorship for women
teams uh yeah please feel free to reach
out we're we're always open to talk and
we'd love to hear from you
oh Karina
I love it thank you so much and before
we leave I just want to say like all of
us are busy all of us are taking our
time to come here and like really focus
on not just women in gaming but
marginalized voices it's so important to
be heard and to be seen and that is why
we created games for games and having me
go on who's like making her own game and
like it's incredible I know you guys saw
the trailer it's super incredible please
go check it out go wishlist the spirit
lift is so good and also make sure you
check out all the games that Wing's
helping to to develop go wish list those
games because it's really really
important it helps their algorithm
Karina thank you so much for taking the
time to come on I love that hoodie thank
you I don't know if you know but my
pleasure yeah no I do it was between a
Hello Kitty uh hoodie or this and I was
like I guess I should try to like we
should have all done everything next
time
love it
beautiful guest guys make sure you go
follow everything that Wings is doing
they are creating the change that we
want to see in the industry but before
we go totally Nico that was great I mean
like listen I think all the I just have
to say this again I think all the
questions you had were absolutely
amazing this is why we are going to have
a long time we'll do a whole session a
whole session on game devs and Karina
and everybody from Wings is gonna be a
huge party but thank you for coming on
and and spending some time with us thank
you for allowing us to share this I'm so
happy I got to yeah and and thank you
for letting us show some new footage of
uh the spirit list which is an
incredible game if you guys like spooky
and cute you have to check it out like
the music is incredible the art style is
incredible and like maybe it's like it
really is it's it's so good but Miko if
people wanted to find you and they want
to find more about Spirit lift like drop
your socials drop everything I know you
also stream tell the people I love you
yeah so you can find out more about our
games on pretty smartgames.com and you
can find more about the spirit lift
which you know she's done a great job
pitching it already it is a deck
building roguelike in a haunted hotel
and it is spooky and cute
um you can go to thespiritlift.com and
you can also watch me make the game live
every week on Twitch at twitch.tv Dr
mikachu
awesome yo how how many people get to
say that they're watching somebody
produce a game like that's incredible
it's really fun I'm a lot of people like
to work alongside me or you know on
anything they could be writing or doing
their homework a lot of people nap which
is kind of funny and I'm just like hey
I'm providing a service I'll work on my
game and I'll provide you a cozy place
to hang out with nice people and you
know close your eyes for a minute
I love it I love nap so maybe I'll tune
in sure
but Nico you're
definitely be hearing more from Miko in
the future guys we have another
interview coming up and listen it's
gonna be some game play and it might be
me playing the game so I don't want to
hear any smack because I haven't played
it yet and that's because I wanted to
give an authentic first impression okay
so stay tuned me and red will be back
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
oh my God that trailer was so incredible
look I am ready to dive in and figure
out this mystery but everything just
looks really well it like not really
well but really really good like the
rendering can you it's almost hard to
believe that this isn't a AAA game that
we just saw what do you think red
so now that's a fact like I I want to
know the team size I wanna know what's
behind the concept of the game and
everything but it looks amazing like I
totally agree it
it's Triple A Sign and sealed
and delivered so um we are going to be
talking to Chloe lucier she is one of
the co-founders and CEO of low birth
games Chloe are you there we're excited
to talk to you
yes hi thank you so much for your kind
words first of all that was so sweet
no no I mean it really looks good and I
know you put in like a lot of hard work
but before we start in and like jump
into the game can you tell us a little
bit about yourself how you got the
company started like we want to know all
the details
absolutely uh so I uh studied video game
development in University graduated in
um and once I was out of my bachelor's I
was kind of struggling to find my place
in the industry
um you know wondering you know if I was
comfortable working on games that I
wouldn't necessarily play myself for my
whole career and then my co-founders are
so my sister Rafael and my cousin
Olivier the three of us were kind of a
place where we were wondering what we
were going to do with our career and we
have always been working on Creative
projects together since we were kids we
started working on our first video game
at like age 11 on RPG Maker so yeah it
was really delightful that we were all
at the same place at the same time uh
you know willing to kind of tackle that
whole entrepreneurial journey and we got
super lucky along the way met some
incredible people who really believed in
our project we were able to you know
raise funds and hire our first team
members
um so now we're a team of about 15
people uh working on this project for
about four years now so it's been a long
process but we're really really proud of
our of our product even though you know
it's it's not necessarily perfect and
it's still an indie project so it's uh
it's I think fair to say that although
it does have a maybe like a triple A
look in the sense that it's a realistic
rendering style uh it's it's I think
it's important to mention that it's
still an indie project made with so so
much love but uh it's not perfect you
can feel you know the the love behind it
um in all its class that's negative and
positive and I really really hope that
people dig it and love it and you know
see all of our efforts uh it's been a
real absolute pleasure pleasure to work
with the team that we've assembled in
it's yeah I think it shows in the
product you know how much love there was
behind a project
listen I just want to say to you like
you don't have to come on and be like
it's an indie project there might be
some bugs literally every AAA game that
has come out has had bugs so do not feel
bad and the fact that like you went from
the beginning to the end like there are
so many people who want to be game
developers there are so many women who
want to be game developers and then they
feel like overwhelmed by the community
and the industry right because it is
male dominated so for the right the fact
that you like started it and you've
gotten this far like kudos to you I'm so
proud of you I'm so proud of everybody
on your team but everyone we're gonna
jump into the game so you can get a look
at what's coming because I mean like
it's it's incredible Red's gonna take
over
right now let's let's see we're we're
with Sophie's colleague so red let's go
let's get this let's get this started
Chloe if there's anything that you want
to tell us about the game as we're going
through please jump in and let us know
yeah so first of all this is uh the demo
uh it's going to be available on Steam
by the time that this comes out so you
can go ahead and play that segment of
the game yourself if you're interested
uh just a quick note about the you know
you mentioned the bugs and I I'm so so
thankful that you you uh take a moment
to acknowledge that uh it this is
actually a work in progress build so
there might still you know be a few
Kinks that hopefully will be uh taken
care of by the time this this comes out
so in the build that will be available
on Steam uh there should not be those
bugs I hope uh but yeah just wanted to
mention that really quickly but yeah so
this is the demo you play as a maid
called Sophie the year is 1958 and uh
you're made in a hotel
so yeah I I you can Dive Right In Red if
you're ready to get this started
my question is what made you pick this
this era this style of game like what
influenced you to make it
so we were initially uh it's kind of
funny uh we wanted to make a very small
scope game
so we were
um trying to find a you know a time at a
place where we could really limit the
you know the levels and the characters
that we had to work on uh Flash Forward
four years later while still working on
the project and uh the scope has like
exploded but yeah so we you know we were
always you know it I think something
really special about the 50s is um that
uh you know people had hidden lives and
as a studio because you know of our of
our personal histories asked people
before you know uh even before
developers we're a team that's primarily
uh people in our team are mostly queer
people women and people you know of
different marginalized identities so
that was something that was super
important to us and having a chance to
tell a story
um from you know the perspective of the
50s being ex you know able to explore
the struggles that people had to live
with you know to to hide their true
selves in order to be accepted in
society that kind of stuff it was really
really really rich themes and uh we
thought it was really cool and also uh
we like something that's pretty and nice
you know the Aesthetics are there for
sure in the 50s uh so yeah that's the
that's the little you know run of why we
chose the 50s but uh we're definitely
like we love a retro Vibe you know first
and foremost yes
it looks really good listen I just got
goosebumps when she walked into this
room oh
yeah the whole new war like I love like
during that time a lot of Noir movies
were out
um I will watch it with my grandma
so uh I love the aesthetic of everything
and yeah we're in a creepy scene because
she's like yeah photographed
like who's watching Sophie like we need
to figure this out oh my God you are
asking the right questions yeah so
Sophie's being stalked by one of the
clients
who decided to set up a little dark room
in his hotel room I know as you do
creative imagine like working someplace
and then walking into a room and seeing
a bunch of photos of yourself like I'm
already like pulled into this game and
it's only been like the first three
minutes like I want to know who is
messing with Sophie's life right now the
fact that she is not as like scared as I
am like kudos to her she's a brave lady
because I would have been like I'm
putting in my two week notice now
yeah so um Sophie's definitely got a you
know a you know a personality she's
she's really strong-willed she's shy but
she's curious uh but by the player input
you can totally influence the way that
it unfolds the way her personality
develops because obviously she's going
to go through some really traumatic and
intense things in um the process of the
game uh so she's going to evolve as a
person also so then through the player
choices and the you know the you know
there's multiple ways to affect the
ending of the game there's a bunch of
different endings so you can really have
an impact on the way the story unfolds
so yeah you can definitely decide to
have thank you so yeah Sophie can be a
lot of different ways depending on what
you do uh one of the things that is
taking into consideration by the game is
how good you are at your cleaning duties
so all of the cleaning tasks are
completely optional but if you do not do
anything or you do not do them well you
can't have consequences so that I'm just
I'm just gonna say that that's good to
know because I wouldn't have cleaned
anything like as soon as I found out
somebody was stalking me and be like not
even work interactive cleaning oh nice
make sure you get yeah the tub needs to
be spotless red spot what is this I I
wanted to know what this is blood
all right like
you just cleaned out real quick listen
the cops are going to be really upset
with you because you just like a lot of
I think it was I think it was I think it
was the developer
that is actually such a good point I'm
so glad that you noted that because
that's actually one of the ways that you
can solve the mystery it's not to spoil
too much but um
since you know you're a woman in the 50s
you're not a detective you're not a cop
so you cannot just arrest someone you
cannot you know even if you think
someone is you know the culprit of the
the crime that you'll see unfold before
your eyes uh even if you just tell the
detectives just the fact that you're a
woman in the 50s you have you know where
you're employed as a maid but also you
know right how you acted throughout the
game
um it's possible that the police might
not believe you so cleaning is actually
one of the ways that you can solve the
Mysteries you can kind of decide to
clean certain things and some others not
and it will affect the ending so the
cleaning mechanics
um or actually we've noticed that in
play tests and stuff people really like
cleaning it's kind of something that we
didn't think would be such an important
feature of the game uh it has some like
it's really relaxing for some people but
yeah it's not there just for you know
the the ASMR side of things it's also a
way to solve the mystery so I love that
so everything you do yeah everything you
do in this game has an effect on how
you're in the the multiple endings is
always something I love because listen
if I go through and I get a bad ending
I'm going to have anxiety I need to
replay the game and that's really
important a lot of people don't realize
that when you make a game like you
really should think about the replayable
value of that game because that just
makes more people want to play it that
gives you like higher reviews people are
talking about this ending and that
ending so that's really cool
um one of the last questions I wanted to
ask and then I'm going to throw it to
write in case she has any questions but
like did you always want to have a
female protagonist for your video game
like I can tell that it's very important
you thought about like her being in the
50s and kind of like how she would be
perceived at that time was that always
something that was on the Forefront of
like when you created this game
yeah for this game specifically
absolutely
um this project we started with you know
only the core team the co-founders so it
has a lot of us in that uh storytelling
because we were the initial team and
once we started to build the team it was
more difficult to change certain things
um now that we've built an incredible
amazing team we're really really looking
forward also to you know have all kinds
of protagonists not only women you know
also people of marginalized gender men
it doesn't matter we're not necessarily
uh we don't necessarily want to only
tell women's stories it's more a
question of like you know putting people
in the spotlight it maybe are not often
seen on screen uh in video games not
only the fact that they're women but
also the fact that you know they don't
necessarily have a super important role
in society they're not like a knight in
shining armor or like a marine or some
kind of stuff you know they're just
regular people going about their lives
and being confronted with you know dark
stuff so yeah that's one of the things
that I think as a team we we really
really want to do uh for this specific
story it really makes sense that it was
from the perspective of so he was a
woman but then it might not be the case
forever for all of our games but yeah uh
definitely you know putting a spotlight
some Spotlight on people who
um don't necessarily have that kind of
attention all time all the time is
definitely important for sure I I love
that and you know what we're we're
closing in on the end but before we go
Chloe if people want to find out more
about you find out about your team and
find out about this incredible game
where can they find you drop your
socials we want to know
for sure so all of our uh ads on every
social media is low birth games you can
also visit our website you have all of
our links on there
um my my personal uh socials are also
all on their clothes that you see on the
bottom here we would be so so happy if
you wanted to join our Discord obviously
that's the best way to give us feedback
uh have a conversation that's you know
that's more two-sided that makes us so
so happy when we get a chance to really
exchange you know with you and not just
you know uh have like tweets and stuff
posted out there so yeah if you are
interested in getting to know the rest
of the team as well and chatting about
the project we would be delighted to
have you in our discard server so the
link for our Discord server is uh on our
bio in our Twitter account and I think
in most of our bios on all social media
uh it's pretty easy to find so we would
be so happy to see you there
awesome well thank you Chloe thank you
for coming on taking the time to talk to
us about your team about your game red
you did incredible like we've already
started a mystery we got to figure out
what's going on no I'm I'm like
immersed like into finding out what's
going on and who's this person like
stalker what listen like within the
first two minutes I was like
there's some drama going on and Chloe's
a trooper because listen I I already
told you I would have put in that
two-week notice like I would be nervous
thanks everybody it was it was great
um the show has been absolutely
incredible we've shown some games we've
shown some star players in the community
telling us why they love games and why
it's important to them and um I just
want to give a shout out to every single
person who's watching today because you
you matter you matter in the gaming
space and this is kind of why we've
created this and you know what red
before we like jump into like the ending
ending of everything is there anything
you want to say about today's showcase
like you know like just put just put it
out there girl just put it out there
um we did it like because it's it's
always dope to put like your footprint
and to have a footprint and showcasing
ladies from all ages uh because a lot of
times little girls I grew up I've been
playing games since I was little and I
know some fellow girls that stop playing
video games because they didn't really
see themselves a lot or they you know
things was people was telling them of
factors around them was like oh that's
just boys or anything like that so to
have a showcase like this and to show
that you can do it too you could be a
part of the Gaming Community you could
be a part of the gaming industry and to
see it actually done I just think it's
so pivotal right now so
um it's just right here it's it's right
here in the heart yes
we did it yes we did it
[Music]
oh God I'm happy and can't wait so we do
it again and much grander and bigger and
we can't wait for you all to join in and
know more about it uh definitely hit us
up to be a part of it next year this has
been like an incredible experience I
must say uh thank you everyone for
tuning in uh and watching and those
likes sharing to everyone we've really
enjoyed everyone participating and being
a part of this show destiny thank you so
much for having me be a part of this
prolific project and dream come alive uh
but let's also thank those who helped
support us and make this actually come
true so a huge shout out to our our
sponsors Freedom Games
[Music]
thank you so much for your contributions
let's go
um the mix of course being a part of the
mixed umbrella has been so fascinating I
love being a part of this team and the
family speaking of family I'll keep it
short and sweet and I won't throw out
any more dad jokes since nobody thought
my last joke was funny do you guys see
what I did their family dad no all right
anyways Kickstarter thank you so much
for your support you have been great
love you guys and um yeah if you aren't
checking out games that are on
Kickstarter and aren't trying to find
games with any of that extra cash you
got lying around what are you doing
experience Studios who is also part of
black voices in gaming and of course now
with names for games so I'm so happy
about that and we also Gotta Give a big
shout out to our partners
wangs so we've also had on this show an
amazing organization working to help
developers reach their dreams and you
know he can't type I should happen to be
the founder of and create a key game
type but to give you all some blurb on
that it's a really dope media Outlet
serving black Hispanic and Native Geeks
from all around the world
and also a taku Noir uh they're the
creators of the first blurred box and if
you stay tuned we have a special
announcement that we would like to share
with you later on
and the party chat podcast shout out to
Christine over there such a dope scene
over at Party Chat podcast if you
haven't checked them out make sure y'all
do and Destiny uh also shed some light
on some of our broadcasting Partners oh
yo the broadcasting Partners the reason
why you're seeing this showcase
let's give it up for twitch gaming IGN
Steam and Gamespot like so so incredible
thank you so much for being here and uh
listen if you want to keep up with us
because we're going to be doing big
things this is not the last show it's
the first show the very beginning of so
many things to come where games for
games it is not a one we are not a one
hit wonder
you can follow us at games for games
across many social media platforms
that's our Tick Tock that's our Twitter
that's our Instagram that's our Facebook
make sure to check us out because we
will be consistently posting and keeping
you guys updated yo this has been so so
dope I'm incredibly proud of everyone
who came onto the show and everyone who
is out there doing their thing making
moves and creating the change that you
want to see is so incredibly important
and it takes a lot of courage to step
out and say Hey I want to make this
happen and actually make it happen we're
building a foundation for aspiring game
developers content creators and other
roles in the industry women want to take
on I loved every minute of this from the
conception to the realization that it
was going to happen so again I want to
say thank you to the Danes for games
team you guys you've just been so
incredible in helping me put the
together it has been an undertaking like
I didn't know what it was like to
produce and be a creative director of a
show until I went through this and
listen I take my hats off to you who do
it every day I'm about to join the ranks
I'm gonna bring red with me we're gonna
do this together also another thanks to
Freedom Games
um without you like funding the very
beginning of this Venture we wouldn't
have been able to get as far as we have
so Freedom Games guys go check out
Freedom games they have some incredible
stuff on their developer page like go to
steam and go check out their games
please please
for sure yeah they have more like 60
games go check it out uh the mixed team
you guys are beautiful you're always
there for me and you really believed in
me and that I could do this and here I
am doing this with red and all you kind
folks and uh yeah you continue to drive
the passion and and you continue to
inspire me but guys that's
but I was gonna end it I was gonna end
it but like really quick really quick
before I end it um
go check out the steam page go type in
gorilla
collective2023 to see all the games that
we showcased all the games that black
voices in gaming is going to Showcase
and all the games that gorilla
Collective is going to Showcase go wish
with some games go purchase some games
it's the summer time like there's
nothing else to do really I mean I'm
sure there's other things to do but like
I'm giving you the perfect excuse not to
do anything
and uh yeah no they that's a wrap we
we've did it we did we did it red we did
it I know I keep making that joke but
like guys I I could no like so it takes
a lot it takes a lot but I just love how
everyone was excited and involved for
many of those who are watching it was
like y'all I would love to be a part of
it please please stay in tune with us
even though we're saying you know follow
us engage with us let us know what
you're doing too in the community and
also in the gaming industry anything
that's involved that you're doing any
type of communities that you're a part
of we want to hear from you a lot of
people like I said
the industry or the community or other
people of the world just really think we
don't exist and we're not out here doing
it on something that we love which is
video games that bring us all together
period so please reach out to us let us
know everything that you're a part of
what you're doing at us access questions
and so forth and yes Destiny we did it
we did we did we did it
okay
oh sure it is red infamy across the
board that's on Twitter Instagram
YouTube you name it red and even if you
want to play some games also check out
geek game type that's tyt.com to see
what's in store as far as black Gamers
Hispanic Gamers and Native indigenous
Gamers from all around the world
definitely check us all out and see what
we're up to so we love movements like
this because again people who does not
have a voice it seem like they don't
have a voice a light so yes that's what
you can check me out
sweet as you guys know my name is
Destiny and you can catch me all over
the place at dnbc 32. I just hit me up
especially if you're trying to be a part
of something bigger and better that's
going to make the Gaming Community as a
whole really strive and and become a
place where we all feel safe and we can
all really just enjoy playing games
I'm really really happy yeah I'm really
happy I can't stop smiling
um
I guess we'll catch you guys in the next
showcase I hope you're ready because
it's gonna be bigger bigger and better
and and and just so much more so much
more
[Music]
thank you